hubert ne vaut pas le meilleur je vous
répondrai oui ce serait de la prétention
je vous répondrais non ça serait la
bêtise que savez vous de l'afrique
les africains sont joyeux sympathique
rigolard ce sont nos amis qui font nos
frères quasiment et ensuite nous jugeons
pas tous là bas les mines de diamants
les puits de pétrole le gaz et l'uranium
nos amis africains sont très tendues
pour le dossier ne se sont pas
respectées ni traiter d'égal aig
bonjour monsieur van damme à eau qu'est
ce que vous faites là je parle de vos
valises
c'est mon travail mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ces préjugés rassuré le
président mes respects monsieur le
président mon ami j'aime la france et
votre musique
c'est quand même autre chose que cette
entame insupportable je sens qu'on va
bien s'entendre
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas entendu et sont
susceptibles et et il faut prendre des
gants qui ça il fonctionne une heure
aucun malentendu je n'ai pas en ce
moment harry voit du racisme partout
vous faites ceci en france
ah non il ya beaucoup moins noir qu ici
et c'est dommage d'ailleurs
bel hubert bonisseur de la bath je
voulais vous souhaiter à tous une très
belle et heureuse année 1981
[Musique]
désolé je crois que c'est mon taxi
est originale
il
à vous étiez là si vous aimez les
animaux les femmes prises et les
hélicoptères retrouvez-nous le 21 à
temps
14 avril ce fichu microbes nous a mis un
de ces micmacs d'un calendrier mon vieux